mein abend meine lieben zuschauer
herzlich willkommen hier heute zum
mittlerweile schon die wievielte folge
ist das herzlich willkommen mir heute
zum mittlerweile schon vierten folge
ebay fails mit luca
eigentlich wollte ich von diesen ebay
feld zu drei folgen hochladen doch unter
der letzten folge haben so viele von
euch geschrieben luca bitte lasst doch
noch einen vierten teil hoch und daher
hey hallo ihr das ist jetzt gerade der
vierte teil also summa summarum look
zeigen
ich sage es jetzt bereits schon mal
direkt zu beginn der folge bevor wir uns
jetzt in diese ganzen ebay fans hier
einstürzen wenn ihr wollt dass in einer
woche auch noch ein fünfter teil dieser
serie kommt dann lasst einen daumen hoch
bei diesem video da und bei 50.000 likes
wenn wir 50.000 geschaffen unter diesem
video dann werden wir noch mal
ordentlich recherchieren für einen
fünften teil in einer woche
allerdings fangen wir jetzt erstmal mit
dem ersten ebay feld und zwar verkaufte
jemand sein fahrrad mit leichten
gebrauchsspuren das fahrrad kostet 450
euro preis verhandelbar typ cruiser art
herrenfahrrad und der text des hanno
verkaufe ein dunkelblaues fahrrad mit
leichten gebrauchsspuren hätte es noch
gut der reifen noch sehr gut das einzige
ist dass man die speichen nach sparen
sollte also man stellt sich jetzt anhand
der beschreibung und auch anhand des
titels dieses angebotes erstmal sondern
eigentlich komplett vernünftiges fahrrad
vor das bild
fahrrad mit leichten gebrauchsspuren
will sich direkt kaufen das hier ist das
nächste angebot und zwar ist es ein
robuster strandkorb hockey schlichtweg
eine mülltonne in der beschreibung
dieses angebot steht selbst gebauter
strand kopf aus einer neuen mülltonne
super bequem decke kann nach hinten
bewegt werden weiß neuss bei mir ist da
grund hat sich der ebay user glaube ich
leicht verschrieben und zwar verkauft
eine angry birds puppe also sonst oft
hier
er nennt das ganze aber eng wie
besonders die diesem nächsten ebay
angebot verkauft jemand seinen
kühlschrank seinen chor schlagen
ich bin da hat jemand wirklich eine
komische sache allerdings direkt weiter
mit einem kompletten mysterium mit einem
richtig seltenen antiquitäten artikel
doppel chicken mcnuggets das euro ich
habe heute zum sonntag beim mac ist eine
enorm seltenes chicken nuggets bekommen
es sind zwei und einem rarität 1 zu 100
auch direkt von dem wissenschaftler
überprüfen lassen und verkauft wie
jemand auf ebay ein kostüm und st und
zwar ein kostüm rita ein lieber es heißt
ritterkostüm und mich kostüm rita
nächstenliebe angebot verkauft jemand
eine intelligent spielt und zwar dass
hier
es ist allerdings ein katzen intelligenz
spielzeug also das was hier wirklich
komplett das mich mal interessieren
würde wäre ob ihr
selbst eigentlich auf ebay unterwegs
seit ich selbst hab früher wirklich sehr
sehr viel auf ebay gekauft
beispielsweise vieles von meinem ganzen
video equipment hier mikrofon et cetera
weil es mir einfach noch viel zu teuer
damals gewesen wäre
und deswegen bei ebay halten ist super
idee sag ich mal gibt's ja auch schon
viel länger aber um halt solche sachen
günstiger zu kaufen allerdings habe ich
so ein bisschen das gefühl dass gerade
jetzt seit ein paar jahren wo dieser
amazon haie so übel krass entstanden ist
dass sie wirklich alles verkaufen sogar
lebensmittel und sogar mittlerweile
schon eigenen marken haben das sollte
gar nicht mehr so richtig auf ebay
unterwegs sind also schreibt mir gerne
in die kommentare ob du selbst ebay
nutzt weil ich nutze es ehrlich gesagt
gar nicht mehr unser anderem halt auch
aus solchen gründen wie beispielsweise
diesem hier
von flex abzugeben konflikts abzugeben
wurde nur eine kleine schale entnommen
und schmeckt es nicht daher gerne
tauschen gegen nutella glas muss sich
aber ganz ehrlich sagen es ist ein
legitimes angebot auf ebay ich meine
wenn ich theoretisch etwas kaufen würde
beispielsweise eine creme und dann würde
ich war ausdruck und merken hey die
irritiert meine haut oder keine ahnung
was dann würde ich die sie vielleicht
auch auf ebay reinhauen so vielleicht
will ja jemand tauschen also ich finde
es völlig legitim dass er das bein haut
von hygiene perspektive gesehen ist es
jetzt natürlich nicht mehr so toll dass
er da an gebrochen das essen verkauft
aber ich glaube ihr wisst was ich meine
das nächste ebay angebot fand ich auch
sehr stark und es steht dort einfach
tausche freunden und auf dem foto sieht
man seine freundin von hinten nur eine
ganze menge kurden gläser musst du
wirklich erstmal kommen ich tausche
meine freundin einen sie ist baujahr
1999 und den allgemein guten zustand
leichter gebrauchsspuren sind jedoch
vorhanden tausche gegen alles mögliche
einfach mal was anbieten alles klar
einfach mal menschenhandel auf ebay
betreiben das nächste angebot ist
eigentlich ans netz und zwar schreibt er
dort logitech g110 also einer tastatur
hat er zu verschenken
das foto ja das hat es halt komplett
schrott ich biete hier eine fast
einwandfreie logitech g110 an
das ist auf jeden fall fast einwandfrei
anstatt so muss man dann halt einfach so
tippen ganz normale leichte
gebrauchsspuren würde ich zusammen mit
dem fahrrad kaufen zum nächstenliebe
angebot hier kann ich euch gleich eine
story erzählen von einem typen der bei
mir auf der schule war ich darüber
nachdenke dass ich jetzt auf jeden fall
es war das ebay angebot dort verkauft
die man einen straßen pfeiler unter der
kategorie trödel für fünf euro in der
beschreibung steht dieser straßen
pfeiler stand nach meiner gestrigen
sauftour in meinem zimmer da ich dafür
keine verwendung habe möchte ich das
gute stück abgeben als erwartet aufen
mit seinen freunden und dann sind
irgendwie auf die dumme idee gekommen
straßen pfeiler abzuziehen von
straßenrand aber jetzt wieder story die
ich euch erzählen wollte und zwar jemand
der zwei stufen über mir war damals als
ich noch auf dem gymnasium früher war er
war auch sauer auf mit seinen kollegen
ich habe die story halt nur am rande
mitbekommen und erde hat so ein schild
abgezogen was so beleuchtet war so dass
man auch im nebel und so und auf der
autobahn und so gut erkennen kann wenn
beispielsweise mal baustellen sind mit
solarlampen daran unseren geschlossen
das hat er halt abgezogen als der harke
stramm war hat es mitgenommen sie sich
nach hause in sein schlafzimmer
gestelltes penan gegangen ist mitten in
der nacht aufgewacht von diesem ding
weil das so hell geleuchtet hat und als
er dann halten wissen nicht an erwarte
er sich gefragt hey was ist das hier für
morgen schon das licht in meinem zimmer
dann war das halt diese baustelle diese
baustellen leuchte da stand sogar der
abizeitung bei ihm was du über ihn die
ganze zeit dahin geschrieben wurde das
ja überall baustellen beleuchtung nicht
wieder einzige wird sich für den bürger
stimmen verschenke meine beiden kinder
einer schlimmer als der andere sie
machen was ihr wollt tapete zerreißen
wenn wir bemalen alles kaputtmachen
küche demolieren und sind extrem laut
und das sind die kinder die tapeten
abreißen wende machen und die küche
simulieren eine ska liga einfach mal die
eigenen kinder verkaufen als nächstes
verkauft sich jemand einen rollator er
bittet das ganze allerdings als
fahrbaren grill
er hat einfach einen grill in den
rollator reingelegt ich finde es eine
beschreibung auch echt ziemlich
professionell und gut beschreiben grill
im rollator super geschenk haben immer
gut an hatten viel spaß
aufgrund haushalt auflösung ja da weiß
ich doch direkt auf was ich mich
einlasse hier verkauft jemand einen
hammer geilen roten gartenzaun
top-zustand absolut hammer der haken ist
an der ganzen sache allerdings naja in
der beschreibung steht versand nicht
möglich weil ich hausverbot bei der post
habe also erstens wie willst du
überhaupt so einen gartenzaun per post
verschicken und zweitens wie kann man
überhaupt hausverbot bei der post
bekommen die nächste ebay user hat hier
wirklich super abgewägt zwischen preis
leistung und zwar ist es ein permanent
marker den er hier verkauft für 50 euro
und man sich eigentlich denkt hey mal
der gold oder warum ist er so teuer wer
stiftet fast leer und verbeult aber
sonst ist er noch gut den kann man noch
essen nur für selbstabholer würde ich
direkt zu schnappen wollen wir nun
allerdings auch zum letzten male den
juli für mich heute ausgesucht hat und
zwar verkauft sich jemand seinen
kühlschrank aus warendorf ist er das ist
bei mir der nähe ich komme aus bielefeld
ist ja meine heimatstadt kühlschränke
und gefriergeräte ist also alles super
beschrieben 30 euro auch echten sau
günstiger preis für den kühlschrank der
einzige haken in dieser kühlschrank er
allerdings mit sich bringt ist es
funktioniert aber kühlt nicht mehr
also verkauft der user hier schlichtweg
nun schrank und alles 30 euro auch gar
nicht mehr so günstig an der stelle
durch das heutige video ist allerdings
auch beenden meine lieben zuschauer wenn
es euch gefallen hat dann das gerne
einen daumen hoch bei diesem video hier
da und wie bereits gesagt wenn ihr wollt
dass in einer woche der fünfte und
letzte teil ebay fels mit luca kommt auf
meinem kanal dann lasst 50.000 daumen
hoch bei diesem video hier da und dann
kommt wie bereits gesagt in einer woche
der letzte teil dieser serie und wir
suchen noch mal ebay fels für euch raus
mich wird es auf jeden fall mega
interessieren ob ihr selbst wirklich
benutzt ob das für euch wirklich eine
plattform ist auf der ihr täglich
unterwegs sein schreibt mir das gerne in
die kommentare abonniert main kanal
falls sie noch kein teil der lupo seit
und jetzt kommt das auto
[Musik]